why did you um swallow come
wait why didn't i swallow okay which
time
[Laughter]
um
i think what you're talking about is on
i only have
[Laughter]
yes 100 but you guys both went to jail
in sweden we'll talk about how to do
that that's great but but i want to hear
about the [ __ ] swallowing yeah i've never
done it curious to go without it i mean
actually it ties directly into
uh how and why i went to jail in sweden
because
i feel like it would happen when you're
in jail
in 2007
it was it was 2001 when
jackass was was brand new on tv i packed
up my car and and drove cross country to
live in la and when i got to la chris
pontius and i had a competition to see
who could stay homeless for the longest
he was living out of his car i was sort
of living out of my car
our objective was to each night find a
different um
loose woman to spend the night with
and and just avoid ever getting our own
place i
lost the the competition
in in very short order
um because i i was a drug addict and and
really needed a place to
hole up and and do drugs but for a time
there we were both staying at this
one girl's house and um both of you
sleeping with her
no and and uh
she um was out of town we were watching
the house for we slept with two
different we brought two different
chicks to the house
so we're watching this this girl's house
she had a boyfriend and she also had a
dog i think the dog was her boyfriend's
dog
so i hump this danish chick in
in her bed right and like and i get done
as i used to do with my condom i took it
off tied it in a knot and twirl it
around my god
twirled it around and i threw it on the
floor okay thought nothing of it i went
outside to the living room i'm smoking a
cigarette and i see the dog this
10-pound boston terrier goes just
running into the room and i think you
know then when i walk into the room the
[ __ ] condom's not on the floor
anymore and i'm thinking oh no what's
happened
so in a moment
so i so i'm like the worst thing i can
possibly imagine is that this dog has
picked up the condom and taken it for a
victory lap around the apartment and
just dropped it somewhere where like the
boyfriend's gonna find it so he's gonna
come back and he's gonna be like what
the [ __ ] is there a condom doing in my
girlfriend's yeah room you know and
also a bad
possibility was the dog swallowing the
condom and it getting wrapped up in its
intestines and and uh
killing the dog so i'm freaking out and
for the next like
few days i'm just doing drugs staying
awake and just trying to follow this
[ __ ] dog around you know
follow this dog everywhere that's why
you were doing the drugs
stay awake exactly see where this dog's
[ __ ] get my compass yeah i ended up
passing out after a bender and when i
woke up i found a little pile of dog poo
and one of the it was so beautiful this
one
this one log of dog poo just morphed
into the actual condom
still intact it's totally stone intact
and and and i grabbed my video camera
and i i grabbed a video i filmed it yeah
and uh and in filming it i picked up
i pinched the the ring of the condom and
lift it up in there and it just crackled
and crackled and as it became fully like
hanging the the piece of dog food was
just sticking out sideways and the whole
condom with the load fully intact it'd
be like like more than filling up the
reservoir tip of the condom yeah and it
was just the most
i called it the poo rubber and it wasn't
but the thing was that that inspired an
idea where i thought okay well if a dog
can swallow a condom plus i kind of like
if you think about it i sort of
sodomized the
[Laughter]
and uh so i thought that i kind of owed
it to the dog you know if if the dog so
i decided that i owed it to the dog i
owed it to myself
that that i should swallow a condom
myself
to make it even right so so then if a
dog can do it then i can do it yeah and
so my first inspiration for this idea
when i was on tour
definition of payback
like if i loaned you 20 you just pay me
20 dollars
suck someone's dick
so
so i go over to to europe and i'm like
okay i'm gonna do a bit called the
international drug smuggler i mean i've
put a bunch of weed into a condom tied
in a knot i'm going to swallow it in one
country fly to the next country and [ __ ]
it out open it up and smoke it you're
good that's where i got in trouble in
sweden because i had swallowed this
condom in norway i bragged to the press
about you know how like i thought i
might die of intestinal strangulation
because it's been over six days and it's
still not coming out maybe it's blocking
up my intestines yeah who knows if the
cops read about it in the newspaper
and uh they they arrested me after i
[ __ ] it out and smoked it all yeah
still i spent five days in jail in
sweden and and i made that a bit in in
my last multimedia comedy special
but each bit in my last multimedia
comedy special
that was like an old story i wanted to
pay off with a new stunt
so i did another condom stunt i asked my
buddy chris pontius to come over to my
house while my dad was there and go into
the bathroom put a condom on and jack
off into it blow a good healthy load and
then come out and uh and hand it to me
in front of my dad so i could say dad
like that's real [ __ ] you know in this
condom tied in a knot yeah and then i
swallowed that was he finally proud of
you
[Laughter]
he's proud of uh was that the
inspiration for crystal taxi
i mean i definitely swallowed a hot load
it was it was still
he blew it and handed to me he literally
handed it to me that like within like a
minute of blowing that load do you think
any got on the outside
i don't mind the inside part but i think
a little bit might have dripped on the
outside you don't mind what's going on
find the inside
but the dog it went through the dog it's
going to go through you
covered by this is a different condom
different condom his boy came in yeah
but it's inside the condom none of the
[ __ ] is actually touching it god didn't
swallow that [ __ ] no i'm not gonna do it
i'm not stephen
i don't think any condom was past the
knot so no i don't think anything any
semen
you don't even know i don't think
because you're nutting in it right and
then you're taking it off and a little
bit is left at the tip maybe and it
might have been yeah i think you have
but but
maybe maybe maybe i directly
you know ingested
my bros come i love chris pontius i'm
okay with that okay
now you want to get really ready to barf
i don't know if i do him yeah here we go
let's go keep going
the thing is that
i i'm now a much healthier guy i take
better care of myself back in 2003 in
sweden it took more than six and a half
days
but this time when i swallowed chris
pontius's hot load it came out in like
12 hours or something less than 24 hours
i [ __ ] out this this condom full of [ __ ]
yeah and i went running upstairs my dad
was still staying in my house dad dad
check it out it already came out and so
i had it
and i saved it then when i actually
taped the special
i
invited my dad out onto the stage with
chris pontius
i unpacked this actually shit-covered
cum-filled condom which i had [ __ ] out
and it's all brown and [ __ ]
and i said dad
i'm swallowing it again
how many won't support
[Laughter]
i mean yeah yeah it's time to [ __ ]
something out and not have any [ __ ] on
it
yeah
and and i want to give credit for that
idea too
this is good attorney hinchcliffe oh
really
i had a draft of of the show because you
know i was cutting it all together with
the multimedia and i had a draft i was
getting ready to tape the special
and um i brought tony hinchcliffe over
when i screened it for him to get notes
and feedback and stuff and tony saw
me swallow the condom from my dad and
and i think i said i'd still have it he
goes dude swallow it again on stage
special
i was like i think that might be too
much
no no
that might be too much but
i'm in
you